oui
juste au dessus des nuages entre ciel et
terre l'île de la réunion nous dévoile
un paysage inattendu désertique et
lunaire la plaine des sables se réveille
dans la fraîcheur du petit matin
nous sommes au mois de juillet c'est
l'hiver austral est à 2000 mètres
d'altitude
les gelées matinales sont fréquentes
les nuages arrivant de l'est aubras
directement le volcan baignant le lieu
dans un univers et rouge
les hordes du nuage montrent sans cesse
à l'assaut des montagnes se délestant de
grandes quantités d'eau
six mètres en moyenne tombe chaque année
sur ce massif à titre de comparaison
c'est dix fois plus qu'à paris
mélo ne fait que passer le sol est
composé de roches ultra poreuse
d'empilement de blocs de scories
l'eau s'infiltre et dévale les pentes
creusant de profonds de rabin
rivière des remparts
rivière langevin rivière de l'est toutes
sont directement nés des eaux du volcan
puis le soleil apparaît semblant bloquée
les nuages au moins pour un temps
la température grimpe alors subitement
pouvant atteindre plus de 20 degrés
le sol s'assèche brusquement
les plantes qui ont réussi à s'installer
dans cet univers hostile ont développé
nombre de stratagèmes afin de mener à
bien leur existence
on avait juste à sion est plutôt basse
et ramassée au sol assure un meilleur
maintien est moins forte prise au vent
n'oublions pas que les têtes ou violents
cyclones peuvent ravagé l'île avec des
vents violents soufflant jusqu'à 250
kilomètres à l'heure
peu d'arbres ont élu domicile dans ce
milieu toutefois à la limite de la
végétation de branlées de bruit hier une
formation forestière semble avoir trouvé
sa place
dans la course à la vie chaque morceau
de terre chaque branche jacques pierre
deviennent des endroits susceptibles
d'accueillir de nouvelles espèces
végétales
quelques rares tamarins temps de dresser
leurs branches dans des poses tortueuse
accompagné de bois de fleurs jaunes qui
trouve ici un endroit idéal pour
déployer leurs corolles des andes à
villé des branles ils trouvent aussi
leur compte
si l'endroit est idéal c'est parce qu'un
arbre particulier a élu domicile ici
là où les autres se débattent pour
survivre lui a su tirer partie des
éléments qui font ce paysage cet arbre
c'est le sophora dénis data
petit tamarin des hauts
et si l'ombre de cet arbre semble
convenir à d'autres ce n'est pas tant
pour sa protection contre les rayons
ardents du soleil il le couvert contre
le froid ou le veau mais aussi paradoxal
que ça paraisse il leur apporte quelque
chose d'essentiel là où ils ne manquent
vraiment qu'une chose l'eau
pour comprendre approchons nous un peu
les petites feuilles nombreuses sont
garnis de poils blancs sur les deux
faces de même sur les branches un duvet
couvre l'intégralité du bois mais à quoi
peuvent bien servir ces poils
sûrement pas l'araignée pour escalader
voyons ce qui se passe lorsqu'un nuage
traverse la plante
oui
des gouttelettes qui entrent en contact
avec les feuilles et les branches sont
retenus par des millions de poils hills
agglomère petit à petit forme en dégoûte
de plus en plus grosse jusqu'à ce
qu'elle le soit assez pour tomber
l'arbre goutte à goutte et s'écoute en
permanence
non
les microparticules de aux poussées par
le vent sont transformées en pluie ainsi
non seulement le feuillage profite du
précieux liquide mes racines bénéficie
d'un arrosage non négligeable sur ce sol
squelettiques
oui
les gouttes gonfle doucement puis trop
lourde elle chute entraînées par leur
propre poids
et ça recommence
les fleurs et des aussi son couverte
d'un épais du verre les jeunes couteau
semble enveloppée dans un manteau de
fourrure
et ce fort à forme de petits peuplement
de 3,10 mètres de boue accompagné de
quelques espèces surtout dans la région
du volcan
m
et
le petit tamarin des hauts des bleus à
ces magnifiques grappes de fleurs jaunes
de nombreux oiseaux vers vienne prendre
leurs quartiers d'hiver dans les
environs
la floraison s'étale du mois de juin
jusqu'au mois de septembre
nous
une fois féconder un fruit en forme de
goutte va se former au centre de la
fleur
puis il va s'allonger et grossir
des renflements vont apparaître le long
des gosses créé par les graines qui
gonfle à l'intérieur enfin elles vont
adopter leur forme définitive anguleuses
avec des ailes étroite
la matière qui constitue les gousses
l'ailier jeu permettant à la fois une
grande protection des graines et une
flottabilité adapté aux voyages
elles restent longtemps suspendue à
l'arbre mais qui n'est pas rare de voir
des gosses de l'année précédente séché
et balancé par le vent
les graines tombé au sol sont jaunes
de petits plombs germeront les
participants ainsi à l'extension et à la
pérennité de l'espèce
mais les oiseaux verts ne sont pas les
seuls à monter dans les eaux pendant
l'hiver les oiseaux blancs sont arrivés
en colonie entière ils vont bruyamment
d'arbre en arbre butinant fleurs après
fleurs avec un appétit féroce il se
délecte du nectar d'enfer par dame
nature
le vent le froid la pluie le brouillard
ne semble pas les déranger
il semble que les calices jaune ne s'est
jamais et elle des cornes d'abondance à
preuve les oiseaux les uns après les
autres chacun participe à son tour à la
fécondation des fleurs
mais
la théorie initie par darwin selon
laquelle les plantes ont buté s'adapte
se prouve encore ici mon corps à cilaos
ou une autre espèce a vu le jour qui
elle fleurit en été
peut être verrons nous un jour l'arbre
évolue encore et se transformer afin de
donner naissance à d'autres espèces
adaptées à des zones différentes de la
diversité de climats et d'altitude dont
dispose l'île de la réunion
parmi les nombreuses graines arrivé au
gré des hasards sur l'île l'ancêtre du
sophora a su tirer parti de ce nouveau
territoire il s'est transformé à évoluer
pour mieux s'intégrer à son
environnement et à ses occupants il est
devenu une nouvelle espèce n'existant
qui s'y est un élément à part entière de
ce milieu
où